IN 1960.
THERE IS NO COST TO THEM.
THE COST IS ENTIRELY ON YOU, BUT
DON'T COMPLAIN OR ELSE THEY CALL
YOU HITLER.
WE WANTED A CLOSER LOOK AT THE
FACTS THE ON THE STORIES THAT WE
SPOKE TO THE ACTING ICE
DIRECTOR.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
YOU'VE HEARD PROMINENT PEOPLE
COMPARE YOUR BEHAVIOR TO THAT OF
THE, , HOW DO YOU RESPOND?
>> THEY ARE SIMPLY ENFORCING
LAWS ENACTED BY CONGRESS.
I WAS THERE WAS THIS MUCH
OUTRAGE ABOUT SEPARATION OF
FAMILIES.
I WISH WE MET WITH MOTHERS AND
FATHERS WHOSE CHILDREN WERE
KILLED BY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
JEWISH CITIZEN CHILDREN THAT
WERE KILLED AND SEPARATED FROM
THEIR FAMILY FOREVER.
I THINK PEOPLE ON THE HILL NEED
TO STRAIGHTEN THEMSELVES OUT.
LET'S PROTECT AMERICAN CITIZENS
AS MUCH AS YOU ARE LOBBYING FOR
THE LEGAL ALIEN.
>> WE ARE ABOUT TO TALK TO ONE
OF THOSE PARENTS WHOSE CHILDREN
WERE KILLED.
>> THE IMMEDIATE LAST FEW DAYS I
HAVE BEEN INCENSED BY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BY POLITICIANS.
THEY SAY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO USE
THESE CHILDREN AS POLITICAL
PONS.
THEY ARE HAVING A SIDESHOW FOR
THESE CHILDREN TALKING ABOUT THE
ISSUE.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WANTS
CONGRESS TO FIX IT AND NO ONE IS
TALKING ABOUT THE UNDERLYING
REASON FOR THE WHOLE ARGUMENT.
ARE THESE FAMILIES ESCAPING FEAR
AND PERSECUTION?
OVER 80% OF THESE CLAIMS ARE
FRIVOLOUS.
THESE PARENTS THEMSELVES ARE
USING THEIR CHILDREN AS PAWNS,
AND AS FAR AS SEPARATION OF
FAMILIES ARE CONCERNED, YOU HAVE
TO PUT THE BLAME ON THE PARENTS.
THEY ARE CHOOSING TO ENTER
BETWEEN THE PORTS OF ENTRY AND
THEY KNOW THEY WILL BE SEPARATED
BUT THEY WANT TO BLAME THE
GOVERNMENT WHEN WE ARE FORCED TO
DO THAT.
SO LET'S PUT THE BLAME ON WHO
ADVISED.
>> Tucker: WHILE YOU DON'T
MAKE THE POLICIES OF COURSE.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF WE DO WHAT
WE ARE HEARING WE MUST DO, WHICH
IS GIVING IMMEDIATELY AUTOMATIC
AMNESTY WITH ANYONE CROSSING
ILLEGALLY WITH A MINOR CHILD IN
TOW?
>> THAT'S WHAT'S BEEN DONE.
LET ME TELL YOU THE WAY IT WORKS
RIGHT NOW.
UNDER THE AGREEMENT, IF A FAMILY
COMES IN OUR CUSTODY, WE CAN
HOLD THEM FOR LESS THAN 20 DAYS
AND RELEASE THEM.
MOST OF THEM END UP IN
IMMIGRATION COURT.
IMMIGRATION COURT ORDERED 40,000
AND SO WE WANT TO HAVE CONGRESS
TO CHANGE THE LAW SO WE CAN KEEP
THESE PEOPLE DETAINED AND,
BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIKE THE FINAL
DECISION DOESN'T MEAN WE FORGET
ABOUT IT.
LAST YEAR WHEN WE WENT AND
LOOKED FOR THESE FAMILIES, I GOT
HUNDREDS OF LETTERS SAYING, HOW
DARE YOU PUT YOUR FINITE
RESOURCES FOR WOMEN AND
CHILDREN.
I SAID, WAIT A MINUTE, BECAUSE
YOU DON'T LIKE THE DECISION,